was anybody in my box you were in my
mock session weren't you you were no
okay
good then nothing will be it'll all be
new
um
would you knock on the door and ask
Heather if we're all right to get going
oh thanks
you're good just go
no no no no no she is Renee yep okay
sorry I couldn't tell
from Keen we good
such respect oh look at you
than anybody else
yeah freshman year
so uh welcome everyone to legislative
Administration I am uh For Better or
Worse your chairman
um Greg Hill
um we have the pleasure of having
another chairman in the in the room at
one point here in this same committee
um
representative Janet wall was chair my
first year in this committee I think
um and and we've alternated
um so last year I was the chair here as
well
um we only have seven bills
um which is going to be
a nice comfortable
time for us so that shouldn't be an
issue we don't have to cram anything in
I just wanted to give you a couple
minutes of procedure that we use in in
legislative Administration
I have a feeling it's similar to what
other committees are doing but it
doesn't necessarily work that way
um I am a stickler for time we're
already 10 minutes late here
which drives me a little crazy but I'll
get over it
um I um
specifically when it comes to the public
is when I'm more concerned
anybody that takes the time to be here I
I want us to be ready when if it says 10
o'clock for hearings I want us to be
here at 10 o'clock
if you're not
please let either Janet
Vanessa who's not here or I by the way
Janet is our vice chair and Janet is
attending
um the chairs and vice chairs have been
asked to attend uh what's it called
what do they call the active active
shooter training or or something the
safety training yeah yeah so what is it
called
it's
training yeah something like that
I called Vanessa okay
so anyway for those watching at home
so
um the idea is uh that Vanessa will
um will be here always
Deb Hobson is our clerk Deb will always
be there
uh Janet will always be there
but other than that
um the only other person that has an
assigned seat is uh is Steve down at the
end here
um who is going to help us if we have
any problems in the room of a disruptive
nature
um
well yeah that's a problem isn't it
there's a whole nother code I gotta come
up with
um
but I will be the one if there is uh if
there's some kind of disruption and I've
never seen it in our committee
we really don't have a volatile
committee we don't have that kind of
issue but if necessary I'll have Steve
go and get one of our security people
um so that seat is off limits everything
else
um I
I would rather treat everybody as an
adult you can sit where you want to sit
um whatever you're comfortable with
um if you're not comfortable where you
are then
get up and move as far as I'm concerned
um the only other things that I want to
make sure that we know things that
present our appearance to the public
so you'll notice things like coffee cups
and other type stuff
so there's a little shelf underneath
here
um that's really a great place to uh to
to stick stuff
um it uh we're supposed to look like
we're professionals we are supposed to
look like we are here
um not to eat our bologna sandwiches
while people are testifying or something
like that so
um if you don't mind that would be great
um I also uh will bring up a little bit
about uh the testimony when someone is
here testifying
um
that's where our attention should be
it shouldn't be
in our computers or on our phones or
anything like that we are here to
that's why they call it a public hearing
we are here to hear from the public what
they think
um
consistent with that when
they stop I will typically ask if they
would be willing to take questions
that's the time for you
to get clarification on what they're
telling us
um it's not a time to debate it's not a
time to
antagonize or belittle or anything it is
just strictly to interpret what they're
saying and get clarification and and
then we thank them and and off they go
we can talk about that later when we do
exec sessions or or things like that
um all questions to the chair come
through me so
um you know typically what someone will
make a just eye contact and and let me
know that you have a question I'll make
a note of it and then I'll recognize you
you ask the question
and then if that isn't enough for you or
if you have an additional question you
can ask for a follow-up you know or
something along those lines and I'll
immediately ask you if you can go ahead
with your second question
um
we hope to get through
part of the in general will back me up
part of the hardest
um
issue with being a chair is trying to
schedule the time for how long who's
going to show up how long they are going
to speak and and try to keep things
moving without gaps in there it's
enormously a problem don't you think
yeah so I've done my best but keep an
eye on the next hearing and what time if
you have a question that is able to get
an answer from somebody else testifying
that would be great you know some way to
keep this all moving on time I love on
time
um you'll notice a theme Here
so um beyond that I want to make sure
that we um
that we act in a in a professional
manner
um I tell people in our Mark hearing
that you know you need to pretend that
your mother is sending a copy of the
tape from here you know to their the
family for the end of year and and you
want to present yourself in the best
possible light
that's what we're looking for we're
looking for professional and and good
questions and consistent questions if
there's something that you miss later on
um or if somebody wants to come up and
testify again to clarify something we
typically ask for that to be emailed in
um and and we should be getting copies
of every email that come to the
committee if I get it and I'm not sure
it's going to the committee you may see
an email from me that goes out to
everyone
here's the caution with that
if I send out an email to everyone
do not reply all
to come back
no reply all a little warning Bell
should go in your head when you hit
reply all on your on your email
um what we're trying to avoid there is
um is a conflict with 91a the open
meeting law so if we get into this
conversation with all of us online the
public isn't able to see that so we've
got a problem there so everything comes
through either Vanessa or I
um so you know you just you can make a
comment to anything that we that goes
out by email but only back to us and
then we will direct it to someone else
or to or back to you or you know we we
can send out one-way direction to
everyone you can only send back through
us okay
[Music]
um
what else am I missing
yeah yeah sure Jump Right In whenever
thank you Mr chairman um I just wanted
to add one thing that you were talking
about when we're asking questions
sometimes people think of other things
closely related to a bill but not
specifically the bill and then I think
uh discussions answers and all can go
way off in other directions so as our
chairman said in the interest of time
ask your main questions ones that are
pertaining specifically to the bill
before us and that will help narrow down
our thinking and our discussions for
when we need to accept thank you Mr
chairman
you're welcome
um so here's some other things that were
written in here by me that I neglected
um I've already talked uh
we will always be meeting here unless
you get a special notification from me
this room we share with Municipal and
County and
environment and nag
um
one is I think Municipal and county is
Wednesdays and potentially Thursdays and
and environment nag are Tuesdays
um
both of those have new freshman
legislators so I've done my best to try
to stay away from them and let them make
their mistakes
in scheduling and doing everything and
so I tried to stay away
Monday seems to be the and and we've got
direction from the speaker that um we he
wants all of these rooms Monday through
Friday to be available so
um
I think with just seven bills we should
be able to get away here with either
three or perhaps four meetings
um depending on what one of our bills
does but um so for now
um I've grabbed to get away from those
other committees I've grabbed Mondays
if that's a problem let me know
um
and then we'll try to see if we can fit
in with probably environment and AG
they have the lighter schedule but
Municipal and county has uh 40 or 50
bills so I'm letting them do their thing
and they have I think 10 or 15 early
bills which mean they have to be heard
before February 15th or 16th
because they end up going to a second
committee so those they've got pressure
on them we have no pressure on us we our
bills have to be completed in this
section
by March
15th or 16th I think it's it doesn't
matter 15th or 16. we've got time
so um if there's a concern if people
aren't going to be able to make it
please let me know that's another theme
you cannot tell us too much between
Vanessa or I if you can't make a an
exact session
Republicans will tell Vanessa or I
if Democrats can't make an exact session
you need to talk to Janet
um and and we'll work out something
um we've got a
we've got a small enough group we've got
to completely balanced committee we have
to do we have to make sure we have to
work together here to make sure
everybody has the opportunity to have
their votes
um here so there's not going to be
that gets to a good point as far in
years past we've been able to when we
had a break in a in a hearing so that
there was available time
we've been able to look at each other
and say you want to try to exec a couple
of bills while we have time here
we can still do that if we both agree
but in years past I could just decide as
chair we're going into exec session and
we're going to handle the bill and it
and it would depend on who's the here
we're not going to do that
in this committee we will never sneak a
an exact session on you if if no one if
if someone is missing we'll let you know
um
I'll there's more to come on that as we
as we go here's Beth
uh that's fine we're only in orientation
and you've heard this before sit
wherever you like
um that's fine
um
what else have I got on the list here
dress and decorum I've already kind of
spoken to that we need to just uh look
like we're
professionals and we're doing office
work
um I don't care what goes on below the
counter here so you know jeans
underneath is okay with me
um but
um I want I want us to at least look uh
I don't know
what's business casual a little bit more
than business casual
uh questions directed through the chair
I've done that
um when this when a sponsor is a member
of the committee
um
that that will happen today as a matter
of fact so um I the last bill of the day
will be a bill that I am Prime
sponsoring
um Vanessa will take the gavel and I
will act as if I'm from a different
committee and
um and testify
um and then I will stay back there and
you all can ask whatever question you
want
um if you have a hearing in a different
committee
while on the day that we're having
hearings
um please let me know or Vanessa that
you'll be leaving and how long you'll be
leaving for
um
the courtesy for that is to leave
between
people testifying so you don't just um
uh get up and walk out while somebody's
at the testimony table
um I would prefer you wait until they
finish and then you get up and leave
likewise when you come back same thing
you wait until there's a break in in the
testimony and then you come and sit down
um people walking back and forth is uh
considered
inappropriate
what's that distract distracting as well
um public notice of all meetings will be
done through the calendar everybody is
familiar with how you can see and you
also get an individual email when you
have when you are
um having a hearings or something set up
on here so everyone should have no
excuse for not knowing when we're
meeting
caucuses are called uh
um actually Vanessa calls all caucuses
for the Republican side I'm assuming you
are calling all Janet's calling all
caucuses on the other side
um
there's a section here on lobbyists
we don't tend to have lobbyists in this
committee
um
we have generally three Usual Suspects
that come to our hearings one is the um
is our clerk Paul Smith the other is the
house attorney uh Jim ciancy and the
third is the Chief Operating Officer
Terry paff those are generally the
people that are here
um
I Wilt they they submit pink cards to
testify as well
um everything about them is is the same
as if um the public was here we
generally don't have many members of the
public here
um
because this is kind of internal
operations you know this is how we
operate the legislature more than
anything and and the public
doesn't really care how we do it they
care what we do but they don't care how
we do it so um we tend not to uh to see
raucous crowds so Steve might be asleep
most of the time down the back there
um
what else have I got here we'll have uh
publicized our executive sessions
um because this is going to be a little
odd for this year even for people that
have been here well as long as I have
maybe not as long as Janet has been here
um because we are
split
first of all let me step up this is
this tends not to be a controversial
committee this tends not to be a
partisan committee
um
yeah
I'm gonna do my best to not know who
where anybody is
um on which which team
um
but it is
um it is typically Alvin
we're kind of in a committee orientation
thank you
um
didn't really matter if he was here but
that's fine
um
so um this tends not to be that way but
it is possible that we will come out
with
um
a split vote we have 16 people we may
come out with eight to eight so we're
gonna have to go through the process of
making a motion of either octopasser or
an expedient to legislate
go through the votes and it may come out
that we're deadlocked in that case the
bill will go to the floor with no
recommendation and there will be the
opportunity for both sides to have
um
committee reports in there they won't be
minority and majority it'll just say
committee reports and here's the two
sides to the argument
um
I don't really think we're gonna get
that but that's that's the process
anyway
um so um we'll be uh we'll be working
all of that out as we go and there'll be
more to come on that when we get to
exact session I think
um
what else do we need here committee all
committee reports are due on the day
that we exec
you don't you don't get back in your car
before the committee report is here I
have to look over every committee report
and then it goes through our assistant
before it gets into the calendar
so um here's what we're doing on on our
side and I can tell you what you want to
do
um we're hopeful that
we can caucus two days before the
um the exact session and we will know
what we're going to be doing and we're
going to be knowing who on on our side
or
I keep saying our side as if it's going
to be partisan but it isn't always
um so we're gonna know what that
committee report will say generally when
we come in for exact session so that you
you have the opportunity to actually
write the committee report before you
get here
um from one side or the other doesn't
mean it's always going to work out or
there won't be new information when we
actually do a a discussion on Executive
session but yep Allison oh I was just
going to say that I'm a lot of the time
we're having repeat bills and on the
research they have the old
um committee report and I am one for
just stealing the old one or um
you notice adding new information to it
and that's totally an option that's
plagiarism
um
I sent out I hope everybody has received
from our researcher
um
history on the bills that we've that we
plan on hearing Alan good morning sit
wherever you like Alan
nope wherever you want yep except my
seat
um
and in here you'll see
um I'm I'm not sure how confusing this
was to everybody but the these are the
bills that we've heard in the past that
are very similar to the bills we're
hearing
in this committee
um so you will see the committee reports
on either the pro side or the and and I
think all of these may have been consent
calendar that we were doing
um
but at any rate
you're getting a sample of what it
should look like
um
so that's always helpful I'm going to
try to do that with our researcher on
all of our bills there's only one that I
can think of off the top of my head that
we won't be able to do that our
committee researcher usually sits down
there next to where our clerk is and on
that separate table on the side Jennifer
for
we've been blessed in this committee
we've had two researchers Pam smarling
who left and I thought we would never be
able to replace Pam smarling
um but Jennifer for
um I can say without her here and so you
know I'm not trying to suck up to her
she's brilliant
um
talk to her sometime about her
background but she is brilliant and she
almost anticipates what I'm asking
before I ask it so that helps me
tremendously
um
I have the connection to Jennifer
um individually you do not have access
to Jennifer so all questions or all
research that you would like to be done
needs to come through the chair
um so and I'm not going to say
I'm probably not going to say no unless
I feel like I'm wasting her time or
we've already done it before so
um that's
um that will be Jennifer you'll be
introduced to her I'm sure when we start
in with hearings
um
what else should I get
I think you've pretty much hit all bases
and as we move along there'll be more
instruction so no one will feel left out
I don't think
um I do believe this information we've
received from committee research it's
very very helpful just to give us some
background I'm not sure it covers
everything on every bill but it gives a
good sense of where we've been and where
we should be going perhaps times do
change maybe some might change I don't
see that in any of these oftentimes our
bills come out unanimously from this
committee we try to put partisan
politics totally aside think of what's
best for the State of New Hampshire and
for the operations of the house and it
works out we do have an excellent
chairman it's very fair he's firm but
fair and most of the time and um I I
think you'll enjoy being on this
committee it's not a large committee
we'll get to know each other and if you
have questions or concerns come to any
one of us and we'll get to know
everybody
um it'll be almost like a family
atmosphere and yes families do have
disputes occasionally but um what we
will do is talk things out in here and
hopefully when it comes time to exec on
our bills we'll come out with a lot of
unanimous votes keeping our fingers
crossed
um I don't think I'm not sure we've ever
had anyone on this committee go up on
the floor of the house do you remember
anything like that to dispute what we've
done
I don't have a record he probably has
but I don't uh I don't off the top of my
head yeah um but um again we've gotten
great instructions today everything's so
highly organized which is wonderful this
term and uh I think things will run very
smoothly and come to any one of us with
any questions or concerns uh because we
were there once it doesn't mean we know
the answer to it but right but we know
where to go to get the answer I think
more than anything
um
this is um
this is the prestigious committee
um it's actually our clerk favorite
committee
um but it is um
it used to be years past you can talk to
some of the long-term staff people and
it used to be difficult to get here it
used to be that only the
long-term veterans kind of like Ethics
Committee right
um it used to be that you you never saw
a freshman here
um
for some unknown reason for the last
couple of terms it's not been that way
and and I don't know why um other than I
don't know why I don't even have a
suggestion but um it is um
we do operate differently we're we're
we if you listen to the people that
you'll meet in other committees we don't
operate like they do
um so I I think you're lucky you're here
and that's how I tend to operate
speaking of
our very fine
house researcher
this is Jennifer
hi Jennifer
um Jennifer is responsible for our work
that we have in front of us of the uh of
the bills that um on the on the
these are just the bills that we are
hearing today
I think
um
this is indicative of the kind of work
that Jennifer does
um I don't think we have any questions
for Jennifer and if anybody does
um
Jennifer usually sits right there and
listens to all the things that I do
wrong and then shakes her head and and
um yeah see just like that and uh and uh
so it it should go
fairly smoothly
um this is a lot of times our audience
um this is a lot of times uh how we're
gonna how we're gonna operate
um we also have kind of an odd situation
because through that door is our
committee assistant Heather goalie
Heather retires tomorrow
um so I how many years do you know I
don't know long time
since I've been here
um
but uh we have uh Jamie is that right
Jamie is coming
um I've only met her briefly not to
release me but she will be taking over
for our committee and she will be in
that room right okay
um so we'll find out from uh when we can
meet Jamie I don't think it'll be today
I don't even she's I think she's still
in training or
something like that
um
no no
um letter let her keep doing what she's
doing it's not that important
um everything really Deb Hobson and I
will have the most contact with um with
Heather
um
she does all of the con
compilation of the work we do and make
sure it gets into the right form and
make sure it gets into the calendar and
make sure it goes to the floor correctly
and all of that pizza
um there's really nothing
I can't think of anything that that
individual members will have
um except for a question or two
um
Heather is usually pretty good at
stopping members asking things that they
don't she doesn't have to do for members
um I don't know if I said that clearly
enough
um but um
but they are not here to do our work
they aren't here to go make copies for
us they aren't here to uh I don't know
whatever else you want to think of
they they have their own internal work
for the committee and I think Heather
does how many commissions did she do
three or four other committees
yeah so so we're small fish
um in a big pond and and our committee
has the maybe the fewest amount of
problems for her but um but that's
um Gonna Change
um
as far as
Personnel we won't have Heather to to
kick around anymore we have uh Jamie
um what else do you need anything yep
well the only thing I wanted to say is
that this must be like orientation for a
lot of you just overwhelming it's very
smooth the way the committee operates
and you'll find that you can relax you
can learn a lot you can learn a lot
about each other and it really will be a
fulfilling responsibility being on this
committee thank you
okay
speaking of Heather and meeting
scheduling and things like that I just
wanted to ask a clarifying question on
the last scheduling email that came out
because it's a 9 A.M hearing and then
nothing and then a 1pm hearing on that
same day our is I just wanted to see if
that was correct because it was odd yeah
um
so it's a little bit of a work in
progress but here's what I am hoping to
do
um
we have four today right four bills
today
um that leaves us with three after that
so what I had scheduled one of the the
last bill that we're hearing today I
think is going to need a work session
for all of us
um a whole a committee of the whole work
session so my anticipation is that that
is the nine o'clock that you're talking
about will do that work session for the
rest of that morning
and then we'll hear
um
yeah then we'll hear the other three
what kind of screws that up a little bit
is
um
so our ranking member is also a member
of the Ethics Committee
who is meeting on the 13th at three
o'clock
so
we kind of want to hear what Ethics
Committee thinks or has for suggestions
on that ethics bill that we're hearing
today so I suspect what we're going to
do is is have our work session
maybe come up with an amendment or two
but then we're going to have to sit on
that until we find out what ethics does
on the 13th and then we'll meet after
that to uh to either exec or amend that
bill
um so that's why it's a little bit
spread out
um if that answers your question it does
thank you very much yep
thank you Mr chairman and there won't be
time to kill so to speak if we're not
doing something feel free to go into any
other committee you want to go to to
learn how they're operating and what the
subject matter is because that's very
helpful in your years here because I
suspect people will want to keep coming
back
um
we will have times when we will have a
break and if you're not testifying in
another committee but you do see a bill
that's interesting by all means skip out
and do that just let the chairman know
where you are thank you yep
um yep Mr chairman I'd like to add two
other
things to
the function of committee the first one
involves your cell phone
really really be sure not to have that
thing ringing during your public
hearings it's uh
these have been out long enough now we
should we should know how to put them on
mute or uh vibrate the other thing
involves this thing microphone etiquette
right so there is a limit to the system
as to how many microphones it can be on
so just when you're done
just that simple because if we have too
many going you'll see you will typically
see one blinking and that means there's
too many mics on and that can just
between the background noise and the
confusion that can actually shut off the
Public's microphone so just try to just
try to remember to shut your mic off
that's all and the public doesn't need
to hear you say this is stupid why are
we here so
um
the other thing that occurred to me
while you were talking to is our office
is is in that behind that wall over
there
um in there are drawers for everyone uh
keyed drawers so you can lock them up if
you want
um
I've never had a purpose for them I've
never used one but some people do you
can put your lunch in there don't forget
that you put your lunch in there but it
is it typically is um just the place to
uh to I don't know leave some of your
work or or some of the bills or
something you don't need at home
is there anything uh our clerk would
like to add to this brief orientation
before
no you're good good
he's a man of few words
[Music]
um
anything else
I'm going to say we've got 15 minutes or
so if you want to uh take take some time
yep
what's that
no
um
that's about all I know we'll start up
at 10 o'clock with our first bill
um
can't think of anything else right
any questions holler at us and we'll go
from there thanks yep
right there on your on the table is a
folder with your name on it on the side
table
yep um and you also have should have a
name plate up there I should tell
everybody I uh there used to be a rep
here uh David murakami and I the people
that were in my mock hearing
um will will notice this David muirakami
used to always start
um group meetings by saying I'm really
good with names and I'm really good with
faces I'm just not really good at
putting the two of them together
so um bear with me for a while here
um I'm the same I
I can remember pieces of it and I know
where people are supposed to be sitting
but I don't it takes me a while so I
apologize if I uh just say
representative do you have a question
great thank you very much
um
we're waiting patiently for the prime
sponsor
testimony to committee electronically
you did so you didn't know yet
okay
can we should we read along
it's not in the weirdest times
okay opening the hearing
um on cacr3
um
and welcoming the prime sponsor
representative moffatt
welcome to legislative Administration
representative
thank you Mr it's great to be here I was
here one other time and I survived
so thank you for uh
for scheduling this this morning so this
proposed measure cacr3 seeks to enable
the New Hampshire legislature to create
a recall procedure permitting citizens
and legislators to remove an elected
official before the end of a term of
office
so I I was here before with this
um as Calvin Coolidge said
persistence is omnipotent and I I've had
a number of measures that took more than
one term to become law I could name
several as some of you may know some so
sometimes it takes more than one uh bite
at the Apple to get a good measure
forward and I obviously believe in this
it's a non-partisan bipartisan measure a
couple times ago it had all uh Democrat
sponsors
and then last time around it had some
Republican spots so it's not partisan
it's not uh it's bipartisan
so yes this is similar proposal to win
submit in the past now as told before
that a reason that this type of measure
has had not moved forward is because we
have two-year terms in New Hampshire
and if you have two-year terms then it's
not that crucial you know you it's not
that long of a period of time you have a
bad felonious corrupt whatever elected
official you know just a few more months
and you can vote them out
so believe it or not I know that I knew
that
um in fact I'm the one of the sponsors
of the Civic spills so so yes I I know
about the two-year terms
um but
the
intent of this really is not directed to
the two-year positions uh it's it's
directed
at three year positions typically it's
not directed particularly at us
it's directed to boards local boards
municipalities school boards uh
selectment boards on and on and on
um
for example if if wanted to
individuals were elected to a three-year
term on some board whatever the board
may be and they and one of them were
both of them turned out to be corrupt
felonious they don't show up uh they
hinder that they're they're bad
officials well right now that
municipality is stuck with these elected
officials for for three years
and that's a problem that's why this has
come up before
um
introduced by others and then also Now
by myself
so the municipalities would be trapped
and such situations have occurred and
will occur again no doubt and some of us
think the legislature owes it to
communities to provide a mechanism for
Relief that would allow districts some
hope
uh for relief from these scenarios where
they have uh elected officials who just
don't belong on the board and the people
want to get rid of them and they can't
they're stuck
so the the need for this is even greater
now than it was
a last year as a year ago that was of
the time I was here because now we have
four-year terms if you recall in the
last session one of the counties we we
passed legislation allowing County to
have four-year positions
Belknap county is looking to uh now to
also have four-year positions and so
that further increases the the urgency
of of giving voters a mechanism if they
ever need
to rethink somebody who's in office
who's just doesn't belong there
and and but they're they're stuck
before you know for three years or four
years or whatever unless we give them an
opportunity or unless we give the
legislature unless we give ourselves an
opportunity
um to develop a recall procedure so I'll
have to take questions in a moment but I
want to ask you all a question a
rhetorical question why would we not
take action on this and and thus condemn
which I'm sure will happens happen
before and will unfortunately happen
again where we have some elected
officials who don't belong in office why
would we condemn municipalities or
counties now to have people in office
for three or four years running a mock
not serving the people
um
so
a possible
issue that's come up when I brought this
up before I'll paraphrase a question I
got
what makes you think a bunch of
politicians would ever consider a
proposal where politicians could get
recalled
now I don't consider us to be
politicians at all we're citizen
legislators
that's what I told the person who's who
and I don't like being called politician
I don't think any of us are politicians
in in the pejorative sense of the word
you know we're citizen legislators with
with the highest Integrity citizen
legislators working for 100 bucks a year
so I don't think that
this body unlike other bodies across the
country I can see what they would be
worried about recall elections because
they don't want to be recalled
so in other states uh California has
recall elections famously so
Schwarzenegger became Governor they had
a recall election there a year or two
ago for governor
but in these other states the recall
procedures are put into place via
referendum
so here
there's certainly sentiment to have a
recall procedure in place but we can't
do it in the legislature because it's a
it's a constitutional issue so all this
cacr does I'm sure you have it in front
of it it changes a line in the in the
Constitution that would enable the
legislature to Simply take up and
discuss
a proposal for a recall procedure or
mechanism so this is not that this is
not a specific proposal for
some mechanism to
put it into place recall elections this
just enables you it enables us in the
future to take this up and at least have
a bill as opposed to a resolution
uh to put into place some sort of a
recall
procedure the the nature of that the
wording of it I don't know but I know
folks would come up and there are plenty
of models out there of we call
um
policies or or bills
so anyway I think it would be uh the
right thing to do I think would be
inspiring I think people would like that
here's this legislature that put in a
mechanism to be recalled not by
referendum but that we put in
so anyway uh I hope that you'll give
this uh due consideration
and thank you for time and I'd be happy
to take any questions if there are any
thank you representative Moffett are
there any questions for the
representative
yes representative payer all right good
morning
um can you just clarify which Counties
have a four-year term or a three-year
term now right uh was it Carroll County
um or
Rockingham I'm trying to think uh
okay Rockingham was the one that I
referred to that we took up in the
legislature
um Rockingham now apparently is in
position to have four-year terms and I
know belnap has taken up this similar
thing right now
thank you for your question excellent
question
which county positions are going from
three to four years in Rockingham off
top of my head I can't
remember and that's kind of up to the
counties
um it could I'm not sure if it's County
Commissioners but uh we as a legislature
had to bless if you will the counties uh
going from three to four year terms
and I guess it'll be up to the counties
or again
looking ahead if if this did move
forward
if some sort of process or mechanism was
structured I don't know what that would
be but locally I mean which I'm not the
county to your question but locally if a
municipal I've been on a school board
and I've seen uh in some of you have
seen select Boards of school boards that
have Rogue members I can think of some
examples of people who
of elected officials on the local level
who needed to be booted so the process I
as I said earlier I don't know what that
would be but um there would be something
that the counties or the municipalities
would would put in place uh if down the
road if we get this one line change in
the Constitution then a mechanism could
be discussed and hopefully put into
place because we want to there are
people who need to be booted out or they
have been and probably will be
thank you
further questions representative Richard
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um so you've talked about the localities
um and were you approached by a number
of school boards uh range 5 10 asking
for this bill and or the school boards
Association as well as additional
municipalities if you could further kind
of elaborate on that as you sponsored
the bill sure thank you very very good
question you mentioned school boards
Association and having been an education
committee and you're seeing those folks
come in and talk on on measures
um I don't know
what I'm very it's a great question
because I wonder what the school boards
Association they take positions on
measures uh would they be interested in
this or against it
um no and to your to your question this
came about because of discussions I just
had informally with with all kinds of
folks including um as I said this came
in a couple terms ago that was sponsored
by several Democrats and and I spoke
with some of them
and as I said one of the things that
they wore me about was that you're going
to hear we don't need it because we have
two-year terms and as I said it's uh
this is really not aimed at two-year
terms particularly it's three and four
does that answer your question somewhat
follow up um where so I think my
specific question was were you talked
informally so was it there any school
boards or Municipal elected officials
that approached you for this yeah thanks
for your question uh the schools
Association per se did not is not
involved with this
um
I spoke have spoken with a number of
Municipal officials uh Schoolboy members
past and present and
citizens of communities who we discuss
the problem of Rogue board members so
informal discussions nothing uh from an
organized Organization no
further questions representative turcott
yes I just kind of wonder if if it
happens to be uh a recall procedure to
permit the citizens to vote is it like
you have to have a special Town warrant
or or a voting yeah thank you for the
question uh another great question and
uh as I said earlier that's such an
interesting question because it gets us
thinking about uh the process or the
procedures or how this would go about
and that's the the beauty of this uh is
that I'm not here today to talk about
specific mechanisms that may or may not
be put into place uh
I'm here today just to get one line
changed in the Constitution so so that
your question as to how this might be
applied or developed that's something to
be determined if this moves forward down
the road in the legislature and I think
it would be very interesting
if if the legislature was enabled and
could could put something like this in
uh it'd be very interesting to see the
different
perspectives and approaches that might
be used so this is not specific to that
but that's a great question and I hope
that your question can be answered in
the legislature in the future if this
moves forward and and there can be a
bill
the specific bill that would come to
some committee about a procedure or a
mechanism for localities and counties to
recall people and there's also you know
that
two-year positions still are out there
and on the state level so anyway getting
down in the weeds a little bit but that
that debated discussion I hope gets to
happen is that kind of answer your
question
thank you
representative Pearson
thank you Mr chair
representative Moffett we we've heard a
little bit about
um you know this as a as a general
overall topic not specifically to
criteria
as this seems to affect multiple levels
of government
who will create the criteria for this is
this the legislature's job to create the
criteria is it
as an executive board member of
Rockingham County does the county then
have to do theirs does the town of my
town of Derry have to do theirs or is
this something that the legislature
handles uniformly across the state sure
thanks for the question sure this would
be sent to your question this would be
something that the legislature would put
into place or not uh if this one line
get changed I would
anticipate a number of different types
of proposals coming to the through the
LEDs to the legislature through the
legislature to create that mechanism of
that process and and what that would be
I I don't know but uh again I think it
would be very interesting to have the
opportunity to have that discussion and
have bills submitted and and maybe you
have some specific ideas as to how to
shape that
that's not what this is about but what
this is about is to give you all us
legislators the opening to at least have
the discussion the conversation via a
bill
can I follow up on that follow up thank
you sir
so
the enabling legislation here enables
the New Hampshire legislature or does it
enable
all forms of government county level and
Municipal level sure who does this
enable thank you it would enable the
legislature initially to enable us to
have a bill a discussion a debate and
and vote on on some proposal the details
to be determined by the legislature you
know once that happened if or hopefully
when that someday happens then the
implementation of that locally if the
legislature if if you pass this one-line
thing and then if a bill in the future
uh becomes law then the counties the
municipalities or the cities
if they have a if there are some
citizens who want to have a recall then
they have that mechanism in place the
details would be TBD to be determined
representative Tierney
[Music]
this one line you're saying would give
the legislature the authority to make
the change later on
but nowhere's in there does it say three
years
or longer term
so would the legislature be able to
override what this one line says and put
limits on it
thank you for the question
uh sure the legislature you know Bill
submitted by a legislator or legislative
tourist would go to OLS and and the the
legal people would work on the wording
and again the the line says
it's uh to provide a recall procedure to
permit citizens to remove an elected
official before the end of the term of
office
so uh two years three years four years
communities municipalities cities all
those details uh those would be in
proposed statute which which is not what
this is about this is just giving us the
opportunity to consider a proposed
statute to to do what you touched on
further questions representative wall
um currently if there's someone in a
position of authority an elected
official and something goes wrong
um usually it hits the newspapers and
the communities get very upset and all
and on the rare occasion where we read
about these types of instances the
person usually resigns
do you see having an amendment to the
Constitution making a situation like
that any less contentious or meant any
more efficient or effective than what we
have now
sure thank you for the question uh yes
when there's a bad actor so to speak
um and and I'm sure we can all think of
examples of such bad actors who betrayed
the trust of the citizens who elected
them and did malfeasance and and got
into the newspapers
um yeah some of them uh are shamed
if you will into resigning and that's
has happened and that's the the best way
uh representative Wilds great question
that the best way is to have these
people resign
but there are times where they will not
um not that many hopefully very few but
that's what this is all about is for
those instances where you have someone
who uh is corrupt felonious or doesn't
show up or you name it and they won't
resign
um there are examples of elected
officials being in jail
um around the country and in some cases
without a mechanism to uh
in some of these elected offenses I can
think of I hate to say Massachusetts and
Louisiana but there are people who've
been in jail
who would not resign to your point
um they not only uh were in the media as
you mentioned the newspapers and were
shamed and we're asked to resign and
they were imprisoned and they would not
resign and this disenfranchises their
people when you have not that this
happens here much but it has happened
could happen and so
um yes
you would hope that someone would resign
and most do but some won't and this
would take care of that
for other questions
I have one
um
so I'm seeing the uh the wording for
this question that would be put on
you you set on uh on page two the
wording uh being put to the qualified
voters shall be
and it goes from line 7 to line 33.
and it includes things even talking
about the rates and taxes on growing
wood and Timber
um
is it your belief that uh 60 percent of
the voting public would
read that paragraph
um and and pull from it the idea of
having a recall position for to permit
citizens to remove an elected official
before the end of term of office
and load affirmatively yeah thank you
for the question and the jargon or the
verbiage you refer to is what's already
uh in uh law
and that's another good question and I
would hope that folks who do read
through this would would think the way
that you're thinking about how this
might be applied
um could it be applied in a punitive
fashion uh if somebody just doesn't like
someone who doesn't necessarily broken
the law or you know they just want to
get rid of well that's democracy and I
think it would be a whatever structure
if anything happens would be a fairly
High buyer to uh to actually remove
someone as is the case in many states
and I'd also point out to you question
that this committee now has the measure
and uh obviously you can amend it or
change some wording
um that that's uh an option that you
have
thank you representative um
one additional question I understand
that you believe that the
that this enabling legislation is
necessary first prior to a bill coming
back in a subsequent year in order to
create the actual procedure I have that
correct correct that's what I was uh led
to believe was that this is necessary
before we can
we need to do this before any bills can
be considered down the road
uh thank you there there appears that
they're
was a bill that filed last year
um in election law
um
and and nothing was mentioned that I'm
reading here that mentions that there
was
a problem with the process that enabling
legislation was necessary
um
did that come up in that
I I thank you for the question I don't
know of that we have a process I
have been around a while and I've never
heard of any uh recall election because
I don't think we can
um I'm not sure of the specific election
law measure you're referring to
um there are a couple other folks here
who maybe could could speak to that but
again
such a bill I don't think it would
could
pass muster constitutionally without
this uh this little change here okay
thank you is there um I understand that
that bill could could be anything could
say
multiple years could say anything
sure thank you for the question question
no that's not a question okay
um this is the question
what would your belief be
um
what would you like it to see that it
that it only it handles
three and four and multiple years beyond
that because certainly there is a time
frame that this process would have to
take
um and also what what is your belief for
who would pay for that process is that
something that would be a state
responsibility or is that the individual
Community or is that the petitioners
that bring forth this process what is it
that you would like to see happen
thank you a great question uh a couple
parts to it uh to the two three four
year thing uh again I'm really not
concerned particularly about the
two-year terms as I said earlier this is
really aimed at the three and four year
terms and as to who if some sort of a
recompoc yes it's a good point you know
in California where I spend considerable
time
they've had Recon elections and they
there is a cost to that who would bear
the cost
um I can't say here we're getting down
in the weeds a little bit in terms of
implementing a recall procedure
if a and that's the beauty of the or the
fun part of this I think if if the
legislature ever gets a chance to
consider a recall measure uh what if
they
the wording I'm not sure would it allow
a municipality if they felt a need to
say okay we need a certain percentage of
petitioners to
um have a recall election whatever that
buyer may be I'm not going to say here
and then if the municipality wants to
um kick out a
a school board member or select board
member or whatever knowing what that
cost May entail then the the school the
locality the municipality would decide
okay uh we're gonna have a warrant
article or we'll have some mechanism or
some fun to draw from to pay for this
election yeah that's a great question
but that that and I'm glad you asked
that because that's the type of
thing discussion points that I would
like to I think a lot of people like to
see occur but it can't unless we give
the legislature a chance to entertain
such a proposal
thank you any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
representative thank you Mr you're
welcome in the legislative
Administration anytime
I have no further pink cards are there
any other members of the audience that
would like to test by
seeing none I'll close the hearing on
cher3
and we've got a minute or two to reset
and then we will be going on to cacr
four
thank you
it would be two rep Stapleton number one
yeah and then no this is this is a
different belt oh all right never mind
sorry
all right so the time being just past 10
30 uh we'll open the hearing on
cacr4 represent and uh recognize the
prime sponsor representative Stapleton
welcome to legislative Administration
good morning uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you for members of the committee
for the record uh my name is Walt
Stapleton I'm the house rep for Sullivan
County District Six uh representing
Claremont and Croydon
my bill here cacr4
is to amend the New Hampshire
Constitution at part 1 article 15.
dealing with the biennial salary
compensation
from the amounts last set in 1889
to some reasonably contemporary monetary
values
New Hampshire legislators are the most
notoriously underpaid public servants in
the entire nation
while mileage compensation has been
upgraded over time to contemporary or
immunity rates the time service
compensation has been stagnant since
1889.
and as paltry compared to all other U.S
states
there's a website uh
www.ncsl.org that has research on
legislator compensation from 2022 in all
of the states and territories of the U.S
and from that Source
um I did pull some examples of the
extremes of compensation and this I was
able to acquire from the legislative
research services
the average of all of the states and
territories paid legislator is about
forty thousand dollars a year
in 41 States providing annual salaries
from a low of one hundred dollars for
New Hampshire
to a hundred and fourteen thousand eight
hundred and seventy seven dollars a year
in 2021 for California
for nine other states daily or weekly
rates are paid with additional per diem
averaging 284 dollars a day
which you've extended assuming three
days per week for six months of
attendance work
would be roughly equivalent to twenty
two thousand one hundred and fifty two
dollars annually
for instance in neighboring Maine the
biennium salary for 2022 is 26
416 dollars
plus seventy dollars a day for meals and
miles are lodging per diem
well in Vermont the salary is 743
dollars a week
during session plus per diem of 75
dollars a day
for remote attendance
or 196 dollars a day meals and lodging
per diem for personal attendance
the CPI inflation calculator
at https www
.in 2013.com
shows New Hampshire
two hundred dollars from 1889 to be
worth
6 441 dollars today
the 250 dollars to be worth
eight thousand fifty one dollars today
and the three dollar per diem equivalent
to ninety seven dollars
today
The Proposal in this bill here in below
discounts
or reduces those inflation equivalents
by roughly 23 percent in the attempt to
make the bill
acceptable and reasonable
the proposed Bill discounts or reduces
of those inflation equivalents like I
said by roughly 23 percent
um very very roughly and quick figures
it took five thousand dollars by Nam
times 400 reps that's two million
dollars
plus five thousand dollars times 24
senators
120 thousand dollars
75 dollars a day times five days roughly
by 424 members 159 thousand dollars
total 2 million 279 thousand dollars for
the biennium
divide it in half for your annual cost
1.139 million
not a lot of money
compared to this
size of the state budget and what we
spend and inflation
to take care of
expenses in a decent way of remuneration
to Representatives
New Hampshire's situation of regressive
service compensation is discriminatory
and then it tends to exclude interested
and qualified citizens from serving in
the legislature
owing to their need to earn wages for
their interests for their assistance and
to provide for their families
tends to narrow the range of service to
retired persons or those of fairly well
means
otherwise for persons not so well
situated
but desirous of commit committing their
time talent and experience to the
service
they are disadvantaged
by expenses Beyond transportation
such as for office clerical support
postage meals lodging Child Care debts
exceeding campaign fundraising
and even hired substitutes for their own
chores at home
not to mention the inflationary
increases of food
real estate rents heating fuels today
and electricity
and also for the general inflation
that we've experienced in the last few
years
for instance I heard very recently that
the 1979 U.S dollar is now worth 21
cents
and we're still operating on 1889 value
something's wrong there
so I bring forward this uh
proposal to bring some sense of equity
and fairness to legislation compensation
and it doesn't cover the complete
need but it's a start and perhaps it may
be reasonable enough for voters to say
yeah that is fair
this won't come to the voters until 2024
so none of us are going to be enriched
by this
until it's passed by the public
if even then
so um I'm asking for your
support and favorable vote on this bill
so we can move it to
the public the citizen voters to make a
ruling on it
thank you
thank you uh would you entertain
questions yes thank you are there any
questions for representative Stapleton
representative Pearson
thank you Mr chairman
representative Stapleton thank you for
coming before Legend with this
do you have any insight or or knowledge
as to the workload that the legislature
brought upon itself when this rate was
last set in 1889.
I'm sorry when it when it last what when
it was last set in 1889 what what was
what was the workload of a legislator
then
From the Rough read that I recall that
particular year there was an extensive
amount of work being done in the
legislature there was
a lot of public consideration over a
railroad matters
and this is just a rough recall of that
read that
the legislature decided at the same time
to increase the rates
but then there was public outcry from a
year prior when there was a lot of
legislative activity through the summer
through much of the summer which caused
a great deal of expense to the state
that's a very rough recall of the read
that I had some time ago on that
any further questions
no seeing none thank you very much for
your testimony thank you
representative do you have written
testimony that you can provide our Clerk
thank you
I have only my rough scratch notes here
but I can abstract them and send them to
the committee that would be great I will
do that for the file thank you thank you
um the only other pink card I have
um is from
um Joe Haas
representing something that I cannot
read
perhaps he will let us know
and he has asked for four to five
minutes maybe that could be three
thank you
read my email
uh can we have my questions can we have
him at least turn his mic on yeah
it's on yeah nope
there you go yep that's going to go I
thought
so if um yeah my name is uh Joseph s
Haas at hotmail.com
and I live in Gilmanton but that's my
mailing address in Concord and I'm a
co-founder of vocals victims of a
corrupt American legal system
Incorporated
in the mid-1990s with three state reps
and 17 citizens I'm one of the 17.
could you could you repeat that again
for the clerk day yeah uh victims of a
corrupt American legal system
Incorporated Incorporated and that was
Roland heeman of Dover was one of the
Reps back then and Paul Taylor and Bill
McCann just need the name thank you okay
um and uh you opposed the bill I opposed
the Bill thank you because of what I
wrote to you in my letter
email letter of January 19th at 9 54 a.m
I combined the cacr4 with the house bill
245 FN
and I didn't have a chance to reread it
this morning but just from memory and
also looking at the paperwork I'm
looking at this for the first time today
I didn't know which one to click on the
internet
and uh the bottom line
is uh what dick Marple used to say the
State Rep poot was from Hooksett who
I've known since the 1980s
and he and I got together with uh F
Tupper Saucy that's another name you can
look up on the internet if you want he
started what he called the Main Street
Journal back in the 1980s
and I read about dick through his
letters to the editor and uh us as a
group we used to meet over at the
Sherwood Inn where the Trojan horses on
Route 4 or was I should say Barbara
Anderson she used to talk in the
Constitution and there was Andy
melachinski from Enfield Connecticut
he'd come up and talk
he ran for president he's been to all
the law schools in the country it was a
sign he said this is a den of Thieves
but that got the uh you know words
talking with the students and the
professors and what he
said dick was what uh oh I guess I'm put
that's in the next bill on Spanish yes
we could keep to cacr okay
uh
the
250 dollars
back in 1889 so you mix it the sponsor
is mixing apples and oranges back then
it was the Constitutional dollar and now
he's talking he wants six thousand two
hundred and fifty dollars of debased
metal coin in other words when the state
treasurer Cuts you a check or a direct
deposit it goes to the bank but at the
bank you know it says pay to the order
of you know what I do on my when my
brother sends Charles Schwab checks
on the trust that I'm a beneficiary of I
put on the back
uh my order is to pay in lawful money
but of course Charles Schwab being 40
billion dollars he doesn't have the time
to talk with me I wrote to him a letter
that came returned the address Unown or
something like that he's not around
there's only one Bank out in Reno Nevada
but we have to stay on casr4 okay well
what yeah but what I'm getting at is
that
if you got paid in 250 dollars in
quality coin
article on Section 10 it says no State
shall make anything but gold and silver
coin a tender in payment of debt debt is
after you have done your work and then
you're to be compensated and I just
found out last Friday I went over to say
Monica the state treasurer I said what
are you doing you're giving these people
upfront retainers the Constitution says
compensation that's a reward after
you've already done your work so all of
you here that either accepted that and
uh cashed it uh have violated your oath
of office I'm really upset and uh dick
Marple and a few few of them like Ed
Como
I don't know who the other ones are
there's a group of them they never cash
their uh checks and they said we want
you to abide by the law and and one of
the good things I like Monica she she
says yeah if you can get the legislators
to tell me to go down with a suitcase
full of greenbacks to the Federal
Reserve in Boston to redeem them under
title 12 U.S code section 411 where the
state trooper you know to be like a
bonded agent so that we can get the
money for all of you then she'll do it
but she needs a directive from you to do
it and so that would be the alternative
to do that rather than do uh what's in
this bill of going into debased money
that's crap that's that's terrible
you know uh cost of living adjustment
Cola c-o-l-a I mean I see that in line
number 14.
uh you know the constitution on the
ratio from gold it says gold and silver
coin dick Marple used to say well give
us some Spanish Mill dollars
and no that's well that's the other bill
I'll talk to that in a minute
but uh all this Cola stuff us us jurors
on jury duty our also RSA 500-a colon
15. we've been we're to be paid ten
dollars a half day
twenty dollars a day now each one of
those
dollars if we got it is worth twenty
dollars in debase metal so if we got
silver dollars the twenty dollars a day
would be worth 20 times that that'd be
400 a day
so when the sponsor said something like
400 and something dollars then it equals
out but if it goes up then just ask the
state treasurer for more gold coins next
time than the silver that's the solution
I think that's all I have to say
thank you uh would you entertain any
questions sure
are there any questions for the
person testifying
Mr Haas seeing none thank you very much
for your testimony
I started a quarter of and it's that was
five minutes that's what I put wouldn't
it thank you
seeing no other pink cards uh is there
anyone in the
audience that would like to testify
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on cacr4
our next hearing is scheduled for 11
o'clock we have 10 minutes
that would be House Bill 245 and so far
we have two ink carts
foreign
it being 11 o'clock we'll open up the
hearing on House Bill 245 and recognize
the prime sponsor representative Santana
estacio
welcome to legislative Administration
uh thank you thank you chairman and
members of the legislative out of
administration committee so this bill's
actually been in New Hampshire house I
think twice before first introduced by
dick Marple in 2017 is House Bill 541 FN
um and I bring it back to the legislator
uh because it's constitutionally
required uh but also uh it represents a
understanding of Law and money that's uh
being forgotten and uh if the type of
understanding and thinking must be
survived
um because we've deviated so far away
from the Constitution uh people young
people today uh deviate from the
thinking of men like dick Marple uh that
actually believed in these you know this
law uh and now people just understand
which I would say correctly that no one
cares or follows the Constitution and it
has uh no effect on the American
government or the New Hampshire
government except as rhetoric uh
lisander Spooner wrote in
1867 but whether the Constitution really
be one thing or another this much is
certain that is either authorized such a
government as we have had or it has been
powerless to prevent it in either case
it is unfit to exist so a lot of people
are kind of you know partial to that
kind of argument nowadays
um so and with the Constitution
meaningless people are concluding that
the only reason government has any
Authority is solely because it has might
through what it maintains organized
militia made up of police tax collectors
in its Army uh not because there's
actually uh underlying law that governs
it so in Article 1 Section 10 in the U.S
Constitution it says no State shall
enter into any treaty Alliance or
Confederation
uh Grant letters are my q and reprisal
coin money admit bills of credit make
anything but gold and silver coin a
tender in payments of debt
pass any bill of attainer ex post facto
law or law impairing the obligation of
contracts or any Grant any title of
nobility so obviously the key point
there is make anything uh but gold and
silver coin to Tender in payment of
debts so it's just illegal for the state
to clear debt and anything besides gold
and silver coin uh
and uh so just to be clear this Clause
only applies to the states so the
federal government and corporations and
people uh can use uh the modern uh
corporate dollar to clear debt
um
uh so but the states are prohibited for
that
um came up last time this bill was
introduced a question about
um
if
legislators could receive payment by
direct deposit or just opt out of
receiving silver coin uh it turns out
they can it was decided in the 1923 case
Farmers Bank for the Federal Reserve
Bank that if individual consents to
receiving payment uh by check you know
from a state then it wouldn't be in
violation article on Section 10. so uh
the state is not obligated to if the
receiving party consents to not
receiving gold and silver coin
all right uh so practically this is a a
good solution uh better than the
previously introduced bill uh so this
bill directs the state to obtain uh from
the U.S mint uh one ounce dollar silver
coins to pay the debt
um there was some testimony submitted by
Timothy Horgan and he was just like
talking about what coins dick Marple
would have wanted to use or what coins
he thinks they would use
um and I just want to clarify that so
the coin that actually gave out and is
circulating around is a U.S silver uh
American Eagle
uh that's a bullion coin product that
the U.S mint uh produces and it's the
closest to spot coin it's likely the
it's the most obvious choice uh coin
that would use
um and then just to let you know that
gold bar that I passed around it's not
super relevant to the bill except that
it's from dick marbles estate uh so I
thought it would be yeah it's a good way
to honor them is I don't think there's a
better way to iron them to own some of
his gold
uh all right
uh
so the 90 uh silver that uh Oregon was
talking about uh the we wouldn't be able
to obtain that that they don't make that
anymore so it would just be the American
silver eagles and then the other coin he
brought up which was a modern uh
like revision of that coin
um
the 90 stuff that's like a collectible
so it wouldn't it wouldn't make sense
for us to obtain that to pay it out even
though it would still be legal uh
so anyway so it's a good solution uh
these coins they're they're silver coins
they're globally recognized bullion
coins they're accepted as money in any
country uh anywhere uh the previous uh
build introduction is talking about a
lot about these problems with inflation
Silver's like automatically adjusts for
inflation uh see we don't have to come
to the legislator and change the law all
the time if we just follow the law
because the same 200 if you actually
multiply it out uh
so I checked the price yesterday and
silver
ounce a troy ounce of silver which is
what that coin is it's a one dollar coin
uh melt value is 23.88 200 200 ounces
that comes out to 4776 dollars so it's
remarkable how close that is to the
inflation numbers you know from the
previous bill so we wouldn't have to
think about this I mean silver would
just automatically adjust the pay to to
keep it the same the same level of pay
without changing the law or anything
like this
um
now the problem with the previous spill
cacr4 if it did pass then it and then it
was determined that it is
constitutionally required that the state
pay in lawful money then we'd have to
you know at five thousand dollars the
state would acquire silver at 120 000 uh
per legislator would be the cost so
that's why this was one reason why we
should avoid cacr4 and we could actually
pass this or cacr4 require a super
majority of being a constitutional
amendment is going to require a super
majority and a vote to the public
um
so uh just another thing uh some people
are just confused like Timothy Horgan he
wanted to he asked for amendment I do
appreciate him uh paying attention to
this bill but he wanted an amendment to
make it so the state could buy back the
silver at market price so the
legislators wouldn't have to deal with
finding a dealer or something like this
if they want to sell it uh that kind of
thing wouldn't work because we would we
would buy it back at one dollar so you
could get your 200 you could actually
take that silver eagle and go to the
store and just buy something for a
dollar it's it's legal tender for one
dollar I don't recommend you do
something like that but so the state
couldn't actually buy it back so we
couldn't make an amendment we could we
could buy it back at one dollar you
could get would you get 200
um would just be like trading in
quarters for five dollar bills or
something it wouldn't do anything
um but it's highly liquid I mean there's
bullion dealers all over the state it's
the most liquid thing uh it it's the
most liquid thing because it is money
there's nothing more liquid than it is
the liquid so you can just sell it to
anyone actually if if we had this going
on the day that the armored cars came to
give the silver to the legislators and
we were signing out there would be
dealers standing outside get ready to
buy it from us that's that's how liquid
it is so there's no problem uh
liquidating it or anything like that
uh and then just a couple things about
gold and silver you know in uh 1912 JP
Morgan State of Congress uh gold is
money everything else is credit
the thing about gold and silver is it's
in the Constitution that's required that
the state's paid out but it wasn't just
decided at some point in history you
know someone just said okay let's just
use gold for money uh this gold and
silver our money
naturally uh they're they have all the
properties that would make something
become money uh the thing is in a
broader economy we have this problem
called double coincidence of wants so if
you have a product like uh a telescope
and someone else has chicken eggs right
the only way you could exchange is if
the guy with the chicken eggs wants to
telescope and the guy at the telescope
wants a chicken eggs it's double
coincidence it wants it's uh kind of
difficult what actually happens is
people would trade to something with
higher scalability so the telescope
owner would want the chicken eggs even
if he didn't actually want them because
he knows that someone else wants him
whereas telescope is like difficult to
sell uh if you ever tried to sell like a
helicopter before you see like not very
people are in the market for that kind
of thing so uh the um if you if you keep
doing that you keep compounding that
process to the end you end up at Gold so
uh because of the properties it has it's
the most salable thing
um and so uh so it's a good solution
because it solves a problem that's being
discussed and uh
you know it's permanent solution and
it's constitutionally required
uh and New Hampshire is the best stay in
the union so I think we should
continue doing the tradition tradition
of doing things the right way and what
some people call the New Hampshire way
uh I mean people say a lot of things
about New Hampshire and uh one more
thing they could say is that we pay our
legislators in silver bullion coins
uh so uh that's my testimony for the
introduction of this bill and I'd love
to take questions
from the committee thank you are there
any questions uh representative Pierce I
have two Mr chairman
um
thank you representative for taking my
question
this coin you've provided here
represents a dollar as what you said
this is a 1976 Bicentennial Dollar by
the U.S mint this one came out of
Philadelphia I keep this in my wallet
you're telling me that with the
testimony you just gave so I understand
you correctly
that with your double and I'll butcher
that
your bartering system that this is a
dollar and this is not a dollar
so
uh the definition of a dollar
they never defined a dollar when they
first like gratify the Constitution it
was just
the silver currency that was circling at
the time
which was I think uh 90
um and then they went to actually a
lower grade when the coin uh was it the
uh coin tender I can't think of it the
US the actor make coin uh I can't think
of the word for some reason when they
made when they passed that act in set I
think uh 17
or 1812 I don't remember the point is
they actually degraded the value so the
the coins that you US Government were
minting were like 0.89 instead of uh 0.9
so they reduced it but the thing is the
only
dollar coin that's being produced right
now is the American Eagle that's a 90
that's a 100 silver coin and the coin
you have has less silver in it so if any
yeah so I understand what you're saying
that it changed uh and it has changed
um
but if they made a one dollar silver
coin that had less silver content in a
lower price I I would think that the
legislature should purchase those ones
uh but that's the that's the best value
coin that the legislator is going to be
able to obtain is the American Eagle
my second question is is simply this
um
as someone who seems to be
recognizing that value legitimate
currency is gold and silver do you own
any Bitcoin
uh
what's the relevance of the question the
the relevance being that gold and silver
is the only legitimate monetary
device
okay that Bitcoin is not gold or silver
so I'm just trying to get a grip on so
gold and silver is a natural money that
showed up in the marketplace and then
the US Constitution said that the states
must pay in gold and silver so it
doesn't say they must they must pay
debts in Bitcoin but uh anything that
can be exchanged and has a unit of
account that the market teams is if the
market will accept it if people are
accepting as money that's what makes it
money
perfect thank you
any further questions
seeing none I have one
um we need to see who you're
representing on here for the
oh yeah it's uh the towns of rins
Jaffrey and Dublin
and it is uh District what
uh Cheshire 18.
thank you
um
chair will recognize
representative Stapleton returning
thank you again Mr chair and members of
the committee once again Walt Stapleton
from Sullivan County District Six
representing Claremont and Croydon
that's an interesting testimony of Prior
witness here I'd love to be paid in
silver gold coins I happen to like
coinage and the history of it it's quite
intriguing
um however that's not our standard of
exchange today we went off gold and
silver standard
a while back
and then in 245 the bill doesn't
represent
um to what extent the purity of the
silver payment would be and interesting
discussion that proceeded here relative
to the devaluation of the silver content
in one particular coin versus another
um leaves that one wide open
so there's a technical fault I believe
in the bill
but it's it's not reasonable our medium
of Exchange
is what it is in the U.S dollar and it's
not backed by silver
or gold it's a Federal Reserved
denomination basically and you know we
got to work with what we've got instead
of Reinventing the wheel and occurring
additional cost in the state for another
monetary distribution system
so I'd be opposed to 245 FN
thank you would you take questions yeah
are there any questions
seeing none I spoke prematurely sorry
thank you thank you
uh
chair has a pink card uh from Joseph
Haas
welcome back
and we we are speaking on House Bill
245.
yes good morning again Joseph s Haas
hotmail.com yep I live in Gilmanton I
put my mailing address in the uh on the
card because they also have a place in
Boston yep and uh vocals I'm a member of
vocals I put that down again
Incorporated mid 1990s
and to start off uh
I opposed A bill but I like the sponsor
for putting it in so that I have an
opportunity to talk on it
and the uh an answer to representative
Pearson who asked uh you know he she
showed the Eisenhower dollar the Ike
1976.
uh coin that's a that's a Commerce coin
commercial coin the other one I didn't
look too well was that a Morgan or peace
silver dollar
uh
in 2021 the U.S mint minted
some Morgan a piece silver dollars again
two years ago and they were for sale at
premium prices of 85 dollars a piece
but if you wanted to buy
them later this year they're reactive
again again because last year they
didn't do any they're going to do it
again and they're going to be less
they're going to be 75 but there's going
to be more mintage so the Rarity is not
there that's why it's coming down and
price
but what I'm getting at is what uh
I think the uh
the word legit came up is this uh
legitimate
and uh I go back to
well
the coinage act in 1965 was the one that
made the Commerce coins
State of New Hampshire
did not ever consent to the coinage act
in 1965. I dare anybody to prove me
wrong
because
there's the chapter 28
laws of New Hampshire of 1794 we did
article 12 consent to the coinage act of
1792.
and in section 20 of that act it
specifies what government offices are
supposed to be keeping their accounts in
is the gold and silver coin
gold and silver I say and emphasize and
for both
and that's still available because the
the greenbacks that you have in your
wallet I presume they're called Federal
Reserve notes
ious their notes their promises to pay
under title 12 of the U.S code section
those are advances to the local banks
for what is to follow what is to follow
are the gold and silver coins you go to
the bank
and I learned this through going to the
Citizens Bank a few years ago
I told dick Marple that that there's a
woman up there she says she can get some
silver dollars for you all you could do
is put in a claim
and she told me to go read at the
library and I read it Title 31 code of
federal code of federal regulations
100.2 this is all in my email to you of
uh January 19th that that what I
um
said before that uh
9 54 a.m I don't know if you all got it
or not
but in there
I made a three-page printout at 100
percent
on the last paragraph before my name and
address
is the article on Section 10 information
and all the summer summaries a brief one
paragraph summary it spells it right out
and I saw Monica
the the state treasurer on Friday and I
asked her I said
if the legislature says that you can
take a whole bunch of these greenbacks
down to the FED in Boston we're in
region number one a of 12. with a State
Trooper as a bonded Courier sort of to
protect make sure it isn't you aren't
robbed that would would you please get
these legislators the gold and silver
coin that they're entitled to and she
says yes all she needs is a yes from you
all and what I'm saying too is I got
really upset like what I said on the
first cacr there
that there were two legislators
who said let's get paid up front in
January I said no no that's compensation
Article 15 part 2 says you're to be
rewarded after the fact so what I have
done here this is the first draft of an
Ethics complaint that I have yet to sign
the one page form I'm going to just
summarize it and attach that to it I'm
going to file it today I can talk about
it right now but I can't once I file it
supposed to be private but I'm going
against the two reps on resolution
number five of the seventh December
house record
Osborne and Wilhelm they're the ones
that said well let's get paid no no no
they violated their Oath by saying that
up front they're supposed to be get big
compensation ignorance of the law is no
excuse but I won't go into that now but
I just thought I'd let you know that
maybe you could put this on hold until
after they make a decision because they
might say to Monica yeah well let's try
it out let's go get it and if they don't
pay up you know what happens years ago I
found out you had to get five people to
put somebody into involuntary bankruptcy
and that was just a con anybody can do
it I mean all the legislators should say
well Monica
the fed's given you a hard time we'll
file an action in federal court a class
action suit against them what are they
going to do they're going to make it go
to uh U.S Marshal sale for the sale of
their multi-million dollar property down
there no they're going to go and get the
coins that they can get because that 31
CFR says in there off the top of my head
it's in the writing in my paperwork it
says ever since 1920
they there they're a private outfit
Federal Reserve System Federal Reserve
Bank ever since 1920 they had been given
the authority of the assistant
treasurers of the United States to
requisition coins at face value
from the U.S mint and that's all you got
to do is put in a claim I've asked a lot
of these banks around here well could
you write that uh letter down there and
get it oh no we're too busy blah blah
blah blah blah
but you know the government is forced
that's what George Washington said I
think a long time ago so the forest
let's put some Force into this uh
well not bill but I mean uh I guess you
could put a Mika security Friend of the
Court a friend of the Ethics Committee
briefing I guess saying well yeah we
want uh something to be done
and one last thing is uh
I did get a copy from the LBA
of the actual uh
fiscal note
and on page two of three it says it will
cost the state one million nine hundred
and forty seven thousand dollars and
eight dollars
to pay off legislators at 4 792 dollars
per legislator at the 23.96
silver price
but that's
I I told her I said that's only one
option to get I mean what you're I told
her she's a liar and a thief but I told
it in a nice manner because I said yes
you're correct
that that is an option but you're being
a liar by omission
and I don't know whether Bill Dwyer told
her or not I think she was working there
at the time
but I saw the build wire in the Concord
district court and he wanted me to sue
him he said let's get this thing over
with and uh we went over there and one
of the Attorney General's assistants he
dismisses by Noel Pros they said come on
because they were using an attorney
general memo of Suzanne Gorman she said
well you can take U.S notes you know
that gets into another subject I mean
you have federal reservative U.S notes
we don't need to go to another subject
we have enough here with 245 but but I
I've been working on this since the
1980s with f Tupper Saucy I mentioned
that last time right and uh he was from
Swanee Tennessee he he wrote the book
Miracle On Main Street and he published
a Main Street Journal back in the 1980s
that's how I found dick Marple I said
before the other Bill
and uh Ed Como you go to New Hampshire
government oversight.com you can contact
Ed Como through there he even filmed
dick if you go to Google you go on to
Marple money and there's a nice four uh
minute video of him explaining what
representative Pearson had with his
coins and dick got into uh paper money
too okay
and I think that's all I have to say
right other than maybe let me made some
notes Here
uh oh one last thing
one last thing yeah
it's uh what is it now no no it's all
right one last thing yep uh
one last thing is section 16 part 15 of
the Federal Reserve Act of 1913. all
those Federal Reserve notes
are to be they're not monetized
monetized mean that they buy them for
six cents a piece from the Bureau of
Engraving and printing U.S Bureau of
Engraving printing they get the the
paper dollars they're actually cotton
dollars from crane paper company in
Dalton Mass my uncle had a cotton
Plantation in Mississippi so some of
that might be in there but uh they they
buy them for
six cents a piece on the average you
know once with the hundred dollar bills
with the stripes I think they're a
little bit more but anyway so the bottom
line is
uh they're not monetized until they go
out to the local banks they keep them in
storage there once they go out by
section 16 part 15 of the federal of the
Federal Reserved Act
they meaning the federal agents have to
give to Uncle Sam's agent
either a gold
bar or gold in some type of substance
or a gold certificate saying we're
keeping this uh here and Dick Marple
used to say oh yeah why are they doing
that because they're charging us rent
why don't they just put it over in Fort
Knox and Fort Knox is probably full who
knows I mean last time it was audited it
was back in the 80s I guess or one of
those uh chance audits
so
there is the gold there and uh if they
don't have any silver dollars then they
just sell the gold by the silver from
the U.S mint and pay us all off simple
got it let's take a field trip down to
Boston
would you uh entertain any questions if
there are any sure
are there any
seeing none thank you very much for your
my email is available in case you want
to write yep we do have it thank you
final pink card I have is that right
yeah yes final pink card is from our uh
very fine
house Clerk
Paul Smith
welcome to legislative Administration
thank you Mr chairman it's a pleasure to
be in the best Committee in the house
today
um
for the record uh Paul Smith Clerk of
the house uh just wanted to um uh remind
you that I do not testify in favor nor
opposed to any single piece of
legislation just here to present you
with a couple of facts it's it's
interesting a little bit um a little bit
fortuitous that we are doing this bill
as we did this during uh mock
orientation for our new members and I
testified much the same then as I play
into right now
um I I sort of uh just want to just
mention the the way the bill is drafted
it does it does specify that 200 coins
and troy ounces have to be purchased and
I would note as the fiscal note states
that this has a cost of 200 excuse me
23.96 roughly
um last month when this was written
and that puts compensation total at
nearly forty eight hundred dollars we
have had two Supreme Court opinions in
the state of New Hampshire regarding
part two Article 15 which deals with
compensation uh specifically related to
mileage and the sort
um and in both of those instances the
judges the justices have opined that if
you are going to pay more than what is
allotted in the Constitution that is
unconstitutional
so I would just note that the way this
is drafted this particular piece of
legislation is drafted it will pay you
more than what you are constitutionally
allowed to take for your service
um and I think that uh we would probably
end up in some litigation over that if
this were to be successful
um I would note similarly that a uh a
bill was brought before this committee
last term that sought to create a
special class of legislators that were
um in in need of financial assistance
um in in setting up a a stipend uh
administered by the Department of Health
and Human Services sort of similar to a
welfare program and the
Direction at that time as well was again
that that would be a violation of part
two Article 15 of our state constitution
so uh those are those are some some
points to be considered when you are
working on this uh piece of legislation
if this bill were worded differently
um in stating 200 worth of silver coin
uh that might be a different situation
but as the bill is drafted
um I I do draw your attention to those
numbers
thank you
um questions
are there questions for our
house clerk seeing none thank you very
much for your help
I have no other pink cards
um
with that I will close the hearing on
House Bill 245
and we are
done done for lunch is that right and
we'll be back uh for a one o'clock
hearing on House Bill
301.
um
no other issues that need to be taken up
now
nope we're good so one o'clock same room
same time
foreign
okay
good afternoon it is one o'clock and I'm
opening the hearing on HB 301 I
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Hill to introduce the
bill
thank you madam chair
welcome to legislative Administration
um I am representative Greg Hill I
represent the town of Northfield that's
Merrimack District 2. I'm here to
introduce House Bill 301 to you I think
this will be one of several meetings
that we have on House Bill 301
um
I wanted to just try to give you a brief
primer on why this is important
as you'll see from the paperwork that
are committee researcher put together
this has been heard a couple of times
last year this committee
retained the bill and worked on it a
little bit over the summer
um I'll start with two quotes from
representative Ned Gordon who is the
chair of house ethics
he said if you read the ethics
guidelines they seem to imply that as
long as you disclose a conflict the
individual legislator makes up his or
her mind as to whether or not they need
to recuse themselves Gordon said but the
Ethics Committee has in the past as well
as in recent informal resolution
determined that there are circumstances
when recusal is required and should
occur
that's one quote the other is we have a
legislature that is composed of citizens
and intended to be a Citizens
legislature and they bring their
experiences with them we have tried to
strike a balance where we don't want
people to not be able to use their
talents and the information and
knowledge they have but at the same time
we do need to put in place a system
when people do have a direct conflict
that needs to be recognized and
addressed
those are both from the Republican chair
of the Ethics Committee just as balance
is an excellent quote in here aside from
our own member
representative wall there's one from
Timothy Smith that spoke to me and he
said in his committee report the
minority feels that this proposed
amendment to the state constitution
represents a logical and prudent measure
for legislative reform
an amendment to eliminate Financial
conflict of interest
actions in the legislature would boost
public confidence and reassure the
voters that we are all here to do their
business and not just our own business
this is a measure with enormous
bipartisan support outside the state
house with about 50 constituents
contacting the committee testifying or
signing the blue sheet in support of the
amendment many Express shock that such a
provision was not already in our state
constitution
that's it for my reading
um so what uh what we have
um and what we've undertaken in this
committee
um was a way to First establish
um or for the first time establish
recusal as an option
um for legislators
and as representative Smith said most
are surprised that we don't have that
we have uh undertaken with um a couple
of the internal people here
one of which is Mr Lambert who you may
all know when he helped you fill out the
disclosure forms
um
we've we've tried to look at simplifying
and I think that's the key word
simplifying that ethics book that we
have specifically in the area of
conflicts of interest
um
this book is
complicated I will say it seems that
every time
a Crossroads came we added a new
definition or a new category and I'll
give you the example of special interest
that in order to
clarify for the legislator what they
should be doing when they
identify a conflict of interest in their
own
day-to-day management of these bills
but
we don't seem to
have given direction to any of our
colleagues
what they should be doing or how they
should be thinking and it gets very
difficult you haven't experienced it yet
if you're a freshman yet but when you're
sitting at reps Hall and you're in the
middle of a row and you listen to the
Parliamentary inquiry and you think to
yourself boy I may have a conflict of
interest in this and maybe I shouldn't
be voting
you don't have time to get down to see
the clerk and discuss it with him you
don't have your home attorney on speed
dial and uh and it's too late to get up
and and run down the aisle and and claim
that you're going to use the men's or
ladies room
um it's it's unsatisfactory so our goal
was always to try to create some type of
guideline
so that reps
regardless of who's on their speed dial
would have confidence when
when they should recuse themselves from
voting and how to go about that in a in
an orderly fashion
so we we sat and and
um came up with the definition that I
think you see
um on page two of the bill line 16.
um and we said conflict of interest
means the condition in which a
legislator has a real or perceived
financial interest or a non-financial
personal interest in any matter which
could directly or indirectly affect or
influence the performance of the
legislators activities
and then it goes on and and
um talks about financial interest and
non-financial personal interest
um the financial interest I think is the
most common and and probably
the area that we're most familiar with
when we talk about conflicts of interest
because money is involved and that
exists where a legislator or someone the
legislature legislator cares about could
stand to gain or lose anything of
material value as a result of the
official activity
um that's money
the non-financial personal interest
exists where a legislator or someone the
legislator cares about has a
responsibility for the welfare of an
organization by virtue of holding a
position with a fiduciary responsibility
such as a board member trustee or
director
when we looked at this in the old
language or in the current language I
should say in the book
it doesn't talk about
um
someone the legislator cares about
and that I think is going to be where we
have our biggest area of conversation
over the next couple of weeks
um what we look at now is someone who
lives in your household so what we were
what we were struggling with over the
summer in our work session was at what
point from the legislator
do we stop worrying about this conflict
of interest
I call it the concentric Circle Theory
you know you just go father and father
from the legislator so the book
currently talks about people that are in
your household
yeah
um I have close friends that I would do
anything for
um so I to me as I was driving around
the state I started thinking about how
do I identify this person that I may
change how I would vote
based on my friendship and and how it
would affect him
and and so
finally in struggling with this we
finally came down to the fact that there
are some people even though they're in
your family
um you may not change your Vote or or
recognize that conflict
um because of that person so you can't
just do this on a genealogy basis you
can't just start naming people that are
in your family because there may be
other people that aren't related to you
that you do that you would change your
point of view or or how you vote
um when when you come to that conflict
question
so
I think that's going to be an area that
we need just we need to look at closely
but that was the reasoning behind having
the language that says someone you care
about
um
this is in my mind this is not
to be or not required to be a legal
definition
because that's what I uh the opposition
I get to that phrase is is people that
saying well you know who knows who's
who's responsible who you care about
versus somebody else you know and maybe
it's it's nebulous term I don't look at
this as from the standpoint of a legal
definition even though within our
legislative booklet our ethics booklet
it does speak to a penalty as far as
being a misdemeanor in here
um I think that's a mistake I don't I
don't see anywhere that the house would
ever
see a situation where a misdemeanor is
required
um but that that's Up For Debate as well
um for me this is not a situation that
um I'm saying to people
you shall do this oh I you know I don't
morality and and ethics are what you do
when no one's watching is is the way
I've always described it
um
this is for your own decision to make
this is when you have a conflict this is
how you evaluate it and and what you
believe you should do
what I'm trying to emphasize however is
how you act here
or how we act here reflects on all of us
so you heard earlier today testimony
where one of the representatives said he
didn't want to be thought of as a
politician
I don't know about you but I've heard
many times when people try to describe
us as politicians alongside Washington
politicians and it drives me crazy
um
I think this is the time that we need to
have something in place that allows
a guideline or
some kind of direction for
Representatives especially new
Representatives
so that they can understand what they
should do when they have a concern that
their their vote may be influenced
differently than what they would
normally vote because of their
relationships either in other either in
other positions like a board member or
trustee but also for those people that
they are close to so with that I'm happy
to
end because this is just the beginning
of our conversation and and I think
maybe questions may be a better Avenue
thank you and I'm sure that there are
questions so if you want to raise your
hands and wait to be recognized that
would be great
yes representative pair
thank you hello
um
in the researcher
um just where this idea came from was
there any discovery of
language from other states or even at
the federal level to kind of capture
the phrase someone the legislator cares
about in a different way or more
specific or anything like that was there
anything about it thank you for your
question
um you would think so you know obviously
they were at least 50 options for us
here to uh to look our 49 other options
but but it did the ncsl language does go
into Puerto Rico and does go into Guam
and every other thing so there were a
lot of options
none had anything like that
um
but they were all over the board
so some spoke to just the legislator and
they didn't care about a spouse
some spoke to and maybe actually we can
get that information a breakdown of of
what each state did if that would be
helpful but um they they are they are
all across the board
the interesting thing to us as we went
through the work session was that most
of the legislators legislatures
try to Force the legis the legislator to
vote not
get out of the vote
um if that makes sense if I'm saying
that correctly they they were more
concerned with people over using this
than actually using this
if that's helpful
yes representative turcott
yes thank you does this uh language
change anything from the Old Law
uh thank you for your question
um everything on that on this bowl that
everything that is in bold is new
language
I guess I didn't understand the question
I'm sorry
yeah does it change anything from how it
was before I mean it's going to be
should so it's it's not going to be
Cheryl
so does it change anything from the law
you put this language in does it change
anything from the old
bill or the Old Law I don't really know
how to answer that other than to say
that the definitions are different the
definitions are meant to be
more instructive than than
um
leading you to have to look up another
phrase somewhere else
um
it is
the ultimate outcome recusal is
different than what is in the current
law so in the current law
you need to have a benefit of financial
benefit that is
um at least great that is greater than
anyone else in your position
in here
um the benefits just has to be a benefit
so that's one thing I'm sure when we go
through a work session we'll we'll
enumerate each one of those kind of
things but I think that's what you're
getting to yeah all right thank you yep
or any other questions
you're kidding okay you got off easy I
guess and um we don't have any more
testimony so it is
117 and I'm now closing can I make one
other quick statement here so
um this is
this is just the beginning as I said I
it is I I someone asked me
um earlier why this only shows
Republicans in the sponsoring section
and and I wanted to explain that
um so when we held a
a session over the summer to to work it
was held as interim study so we studied
it
um
only Republicans showed up for that
interim study by the way
um but when we did the work on this and
and discussed it
um over the summer
into the fall
it came clear to me that we would
ultimately end up with some kind of a
compromise in here or or a committee
Amendment so I didn't really wind up
um trying to make sure that this bill
was balanced because I felt that the
amendment that we come out as a
committee will be balanced so that's
that was the answer for that
um I can't think of anything else that
is
necessary to bring up in this activity
the timeline here
um from my standpoint I think I
mentioned this to some people that were
here early enough this morning
is that I think we will have a works
well maybe I should talk from the chair
on this but I think there will be at
least one other work session that we
will have here and one of them I'm
hoping is after the Ethics Committee
itself weighs in and and tells whether
this is something that they can work
with and or if they provide guidance
from from this they're actually the ones
that are going to have to deal with this
so I think that's important
good okay thank you thank you is 120 and
I'm closing the hearing on HB 301.
he runs off
um
I wanted I think I had told everybody
why we were meeting on Mondays but I
wanted to make sure that
if there was a conflict or if there was
a problem with any of that
to let uh either Vanessa or I know um
that would be good
um can you shut off that microphone for
right front here thanks
um
but we are planning to clean up
our bills next week the one thing that I
didn't discuss earlier was if there are
amendments that anyone is bringing on
any of these bills
um it's courtesy and I would appreciate
if you would let us know that you're
bringing forth amendments that would be
good
um so that covers all of the other bills
rather than the one that I was just
talking about
um Mr Lambert anything you want to add
or before we close up
okay great
anything else anyone has for concerns
comments questions before we yep
thank you Mr chair so I just want to
reiterate one of the biggest differences
between current law and what you're
proposing is that current law
mainly deals with financial interests
this is this language or this measure
we'll look at
advocation or advocacy as
a potential
conflict
right
that may be something that we talk about
in the work session
um
I think it is I think it is in there but
we have always had
a conflict when you work for or if
you're on the board or something
um
with fiduciary responsibility
so but we've closed the hearing so I
don't really want to go beyond that
thanks
if people want to hang on for a second
too we have
um
we have just a little gift for our
committee assistant that is retiring so
there's a signature coming around on the
card
um
so it'd be nice if
we all just didn't toss the package to
her and then ran out the door so
yep